Yo, c'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouveau Coup de Phil.
Il y a quelques semaines on a vu ensemble un moyen d'être heureux: c'est l'épicurisme.
Mais les épicuriens ne sont pas les seuls à vouloir accéder au bonheur,
et une autre philosophie propose de voir les choses d'une autre manière:
c'est le stoïcisme...
De Sénèque.
Avant toute chose je tiens à vous dire que j'ai dit Sénèque,
mais j'aurais pu dire Epictète, ou Marc-Aurèle,
qui sont des philosophes qui ont fortement contribué au stoïcisme impérial.
Car oui, il y a différents types de stoïcisme.
Mais c'est celui-là qui m'intéresse.
Sénèque, c'est un philosophe romain qui était entre autres précepteur de Néron.
Alors Néron c'est un empereur qui peut-être brûlé Rome, on sait pas trop, voilà...
Euh...
Et, qui a poussé Sénèque au suicide.
Alors bon, ce qui est marrant, c'est que Sénèque, il est mort dans son bain, comme Epicure.
Enfin, c'est pas vraiment marrant,
euh, parce que c'est pas hilarant, quoi,
mais c'est... c'est remarquable, quoi!
'Fin c'est pas remarquable genre c'est "Wahou"...
Mais genre tu le remarques.
'Fin, ce que je veux dire par "tu le remarques", c'est que en fait c'est pas vraiment...
Bref, Sénèque, c'était avant tout un stoïcien.
Et les stoïciens ils ont une vision du monde complètement différente des épicuriens.
Et d'ailleurs, Spinoza s'est grave inspiré d'eux.
En gros, pour eux, tout fait un avec le cosmos.
Le monde est un tout qui marche ensemble,
et y a une âme du monde, avec laquelle notre âme communique.
Et en fait c'est comme un être unique, ou un grand animal, duquel on fait tous partie.
Ca fait chier d'être l'anus du monde, quand même!
Du coup une conséquence de cette vision, c'est qu'il y a un déterminisme.
Et on va aller plus loin qu'avec Spinoza, puisque là on va même parler de destin.
*rires*
Donc s'il y a un destin, ça veut dire qu'il y a plein de choses qui vont nous arriver qui ne dépendent pas de nous.
Et ça c'est super important. C'est là que réside la clef du bonheur pour les stoïciens.
Le stoïcien va prendre une grande distance par rapport à ce qui lui arrive.
Il y a les événements qui sont extérieurs à toi et qui ne dépendent pas de toi...
Et il y a ce qui est propre à toi, comme ta nature, ta raison, etc.
Mais les événements ne t'atteignent pas directement.
Il y a une barrière entre les deux, et cette barrière, c'est le jugement.
Et le jugement, c'est le tien, et il dépend de toi.
Et c'est ce qui se passe dans ce film de ouf qu'est Gladiator.
Où le héros, Maximus, eh ben, il est général, tout va bien!
Il devient esclave, tout va bien!
Il devient gladiateur, on essaie de le tuer, sa famille se fait carboniser, tout va bien!
Le mec ne se plaint jamais en fait. Je sais pas si t'as remarqué pendant le film, mais il se plaint jamais!
Et en fait c'est parce qu'il comprend que le divin agit comme un metteur en scène,
et qu'il faut jouer du mieux possible le rôle qu'il va te donner.
Ok, stop, coupez! C'était génial! Maximus, juste, on va faire un ptit changement,
tu vas devenir heum... esclave et gladiator,
et on va violer ta femme, plusieurs fois, brûler les enfants et tout, ok?
Nan, ah non non, tu gardes le smile, toujours! Le smile!
Yeah! C'est ce que je veux!
Ok! Light, c'est bon? Green Screen, Colisée, tout de suite!
Ok, perfect!
Le smile! Toujours le smile! Ok?
Ok Maximus, t'es le meilleur! Vas-y! Vas-y, go, go, go!
Ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ce ne sont pas les choses qui t'affectent,
c'est ce que tu penses des choses.
Par exemple, si je perds un être cher, c'est pas la perte en soi qui va m'affecter.
La perte en soi ben c'est un fait, c'est une ligne de texte dans un journal, voilà.
C'est comment je vais vivre cette perte, qui va m'affecter,
c'est l'importance que je vais lui donner, qui va m'affecter.
D'ailleurs concernant la perte d'un être cher, les stoïciens se prennent moins la tête que ça...
Comme le montre Epictète dans le Manuel:
Ne dis jamais à propos de rien que tu l'as perdu. Dis: "Je l'ai rendu." Ton enfant est mort? Tu l'as rendu.
Ah non non, les stoïciens ils font pas semblant.
Maman? Quand est-ce qu'on rend mamie?
Du coup le stoïcien, pour être heureux il va adapter son désir, et ne désirer que des choses qui dépendent de lui.
Par exemple ça n'a pas de sens pour un stoïcien de dire: "J'espère qu'il fera beau demain.".
C'est genre anti-stoïcien.
Donc ça demande une réelle maîtrise qu'on va acquérir avec l'exercice.
Ce qu'on va appeler l'ascèse.
Et c'est ça qui va permettre d'arriver à l'apatheia.
L'absence de passions...
Alors, juste un petit mot sur les passions.
Les passions c'est pas genre l'équitation ou la photo ou voilà.
J'en avais parlé dans les barres d'infos du Coup de Phil 9 et du Coup de Phil 10.
En gros les passions, c'est ce qui va perturber, affecter ton âme.
L'apatheia c'st donc un état où rien ne va t'affecter.
Rien ne va te perturber. T'es comme de l'eau, quoi, tout glisse sur toi.
Voilà! Voilà, ça c'est stoïcien!
Bon alors par contre, c'est difficile d'être stoïcien et d'avoir la classe...
Ok.
Autre différence majeure avec les épicuriens,
c'est que le stoïcien, lui il va refuser d'aller chercher le plaisir.
En fait pour lui, plaisir et souffrance, c'est les deux côtés d'une même pièce.
Nan mais je te dis mon gars, le stoïcien, c'est une pierre.
Joyeux anniversaire! Joy-
Waaaaahou!
Popolopopopo!!
Ah... Ah...
Voilà j'espère que le stoïcisme est maintenant plus clair pour vous.
En tout cas gardez en tête que c'est un philosophie qui a vachement influencé euh,
Spinoza, Nietzsche, le christianisme aussi, par exemple;
et que c'est une philosophie qui est pas si différente de l'épicurisme que ça.
Je vais poster sur ma page Facebook un tableau récapitulatif entre les deux philosophies
que j'ai trouvé et qui est vraiment pas mal.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager ou à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait,
et moi je vous envoie du Love et de la Peace,
YOLO!